we just saw almost 20 minutes of ghost
of Tsushima gameplay and there's so much
to talk about here's everything you need
to know from the reveal the presentation
was split into four sections so we're
gonna do the same here
starting with exploration Tsushima
itself is a big island and developer
Sucker Punch wants it to guide you when
you open your map and place a waypoint
you won't get an intrusive GPS looking
line to guide you there instead small
gusts of wind will nudge the camera
toward the spot you marked on the way to
your destination you can pick up
resources like bamboo and you would
you'll also spot other points of
interest as you move along these include
smokestacks wild animals and what
sucker-punch describes as oddly shaped
trees you may also find shrines the demo
showed a fox actually guiding Jin to one
of these just like in the stories of
magical in re shrines you'll also be
able to fast travel between certain
destinations you've discovered like
Mongol camps that's where we'll get into
the next section combat combat is split
into two very different styles the
honorable samurai and the dishonorable
ghost samurai combat is fast and
dangerous with enemies slashing their
swords and firing arrows at you you can
change stances to deal with various
enemy types but combat is really all
about timing with the right timing you
can slice arrows out of the air or parry
an enemy's attack the ghost is all about
stealth however Jin can take out enemies
up close with a slice to the neck or
from a distance with his long bow or
kunai you can even take out a bunch at
once by lining up multiple instant
assassinations firecrackers serve as
great distractions and a smoke bomb can
disorient enemies and give you a chance
to escape the more you take out the
Mongols in these ways the more they will
fear you they may even drop their
weapons or run away customization is
also a big part of ghosts of Tsushima
but Jin's different armor isn't just for
looks yes you can make him look cool by
dying at different colors but different
armor types also offer combat advantages
omma more each arm also grant him
special perks and you can find them at
the aforementioned shrines the menu also
showed techniques you can learn an
upgrade letting you play as the samurai
or goes do you want to
speaking of seeing things we have to
talk about Tsushima special modes as you
might expect there is a photo mode with
various depth of field and color sliders
you can even use photo mode to record
video clips of yourself in action what's
more the game has what it calls samurais
cinema mode which paints the whole game
in black and white film grain in an
homage to the films of Akira Kurosawa
you can also experience the whole game
in full Japanese with subtitles right
from the start so yeah we learned quite
a lot about ghosts of Tsushima from that
stream and there's more to come before
it launches on ps4 on July 17th
in the meantime GameSpot has plenty more
coverage about all the features you
heard about here